et je me tourne maintenant vers Henri
Paul Normandin ancienne ambassadeur
spécialiste de la Chine qui suit ce
dossier de près et depuis longtemps
monsieur Normandin bonsoir
alors David Johnson rejette l'idée d'une
enquête publique indépendante est-ce que
sont plaidoyer a été convaincant
d'abord je dois dire que je comprends le
dilemme auquel était confronté monsieur
Johnson il tentait de résoudre la
cadrature du cercle c'est-à-dire d'une
part faire un processus qui soit très
transparent et public et puis d'autre
part protéger avec de façon légitime des
renseignements eu égards à la sécurité
nationale donc la question est est-ce
qu'il a résolu cette quadrature du
cercle la réponse dépendra de
différentes personnes mon analyse est la
suivante c'est que d'une part il y a pas
dans quel public comme tel mais il y
aura des audiences publiques sur un
certain nombre de sujets de plus son
rapport on l'a vu sera soumis à la
décision de deux comités de surveillance
et aussi de parlementaires tout ça c'est
très bien mais ce sont des experts des
parlementaires et des experts qui auront
accès à plus d'informations le grand
public lui veut de l'information aussi
or pour moi la condition essentielle
pour que ce processus soit jugé
suffisamment transparent c'est que le
rapport qui sortira de ce processus soit
lui le plus explicite possible le plus
transparent possible et qu'il pousse un
peu à la limite la question de la
protection des renseignements ou égal à
la sécurité nationale parce que les
Canadiens ont besoin d'être convaincus
ils ont besoin que la lumière soit faite
sur l'ensemble des questions qui demeure
sans réponse qui savait quoi quand etc
exactement et c'est là que le rapport
qui a été publié aujourd'hui nous laisse
beaucoup sur notre fin d'ailleurs
monsieur gentil de lui-même d'entrée de
jeu quand on lit le rapport
d'aujourd'hui il y a un certain nombre
de faits un certain nombre d'analyses
mais il y a pas beaucoup de détails il y
a beaucoup de choses qui passent sous
silence alors quand on lit cela moi je
peux dire que quand je lis cela je ne
suis pas convaincu des conclusions
auxquelles on vient monsieur Johnson de
façon préliminaire et je pense que
beaucoup de Canadiens aussi ne seront
pas convaincus alors
ce qui m'a surpris ces deux choses sur
le contenu du rapport d'une part le fait
que Monsieur Johnson adresse
la question
clé pour moi du rapport est-ce que le
gouvernement a mis en place les mesures
qui étaient nécessaires pour lutter
contre l'ingérence et café au canapé
aucun n'a pas fait le gouvernement or le
je me stresse attendu à ce que c'est
question là soit adressées non pas dans
un rapport préliminaire mais à la toute
fin une fois que le processus aura été
Mania terme deuxièmement sur ces deux
conclusions justement le rapport n'est
pas très étoffé et donc il n'est pas
convaincant et c'est là je pense que le
bât blesse mais est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'il dédouane un peu trop
rapidement le gouvernement parce qu'il
dit là donc il y a pas de problème au
fond
effectivement pour moi c'est tout il me
semble que dans un processus rigoureux
et complet on aurait poursuivi le
processus d'enquête et ce n'est que dans
quelques mois leur entendit plus
d'informations plus de témoignages et ce
n'est que dans quelques mois qu'on
aurait pu en venir à des conclusions
alors pour moi oui ça m'apparaît un peu
tôt pour dédouaner le gouvernement mais
donc est-ce qu'il y aura est-ce qu'on
aura une réponse à toutes ces questions
avec des audiences publiques vous dites
que non finalement
si je dis bien le rapport de Monsieur
Johnson la question de la réponse du
gouvernement Alain gérance il a déjà
tranché il a conclu que le gouvernement
n'avait pas fait de mission de
négligence de partisannerie c'est sa
conclusion actuelle et ça semble une
conclusion définitive si je comprends
bien son rapport la suite de l'enquête
portera sur d'autres enjeux connaître
c'est important mais sur d'autres enjeux
cette question là il semble avoir déjà
réglé et c'est là je pense que ça le
rapport soulève des questions alors
évidemment on a vu la réaction des
oppositions est-ce que Monsieur Johnson
d'après vous est encore la meilleure
personne pour poursuivre dans ce dossier
là
une feuille de route exceptionnelle mais
dans des dossiers comme celui-là la
crédibilité est importante en matière de
conflit d'intérêt il y a pas seulement
les conflits d'intérêt il y a la
perception de conflit d'intérêt or à
tort ou à raison
il y a un déficit de crédibilité qui
affecte monsieur Johnson alors je pense
que tout le reste du processus
malheureusement sera affecté par ce
déficit de crédibilité et vous savez une
chose qui aurait peut-être pu choisir de
faire monsieur Johnson c'est de dire
mais voici voici mon rapport prémunère
voici le mécanisme que je suggère pour
le futur mais maintenant ceci étant dit
en raison du déficit de crédibilité à
ton ou à raison par rapport à ma
personne je recommande au gouvernement
de passer le bâton à une autre personne
ça aurait pu être un choix que Monsieur
Johnson aurait fait et en terminant je
vais vous poser une question sur la
Chine évidemment est-ce que pour Pékin
c'est un soulagement de voir que
Monsieur Johnson ne recommande pas cette
enquête publique je ne crois pas parce
que d'une part monsieur Johnson
identifie clairement l'ingérence
chinoise comme étant un enjeu ça c'est
clair et puis d'autre part le sujet va
demeurer à l'ordre du jour pendant des
semaines sinon des mois et Monsieur
Johnson a d'ailleurs déjà identifié
qu'il souhaitait inviter entre autres la
diasporase s'exprimer alors au cours des
prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois la Chine va continuer à entendre
des débats au Canada sur l'ingérence ça
va la gêner surtout dans le contexte de
la réunion du G7 le week-end dernier ou
le thème de l'ingérence chinoise a été
mis à l'agenda donc ça va pas améliorer
nos relations avec la Chine et on n'a
pas fini d'en parler merci beaucoup
Monsieur Laurent très clair ça m'a fait
plaisir